foreign
thank you everybody for coming it's
great music to walk on to by the way I'm
accustomed to walking on to Phil Collins
songs so that's by far the best music
I've ever walked onto a stage two there
was only one occasion when being called
Phil Collins was at all useful there was
one moment when Peter Gabriel came into
Downing Street to lobbyists for
performance rights with Bob Geldof and I
went down to join the meeting and he
came over I agree to him and he shook
his held his hand out he's a very
friendly man he held his hand out and
said good afternoon my name is Peter
Gabriel and I said hi I'm Phil Collins
I'm I'm so glad we could get back
together again
at which the Prime Minister looked at us
both and said do you two know each other
I said no you idiot it's a Genesis joke
I sort of cut my teeth writing speeches
for the Prime Minister Tony Blair since
then I've written for lots of other
people too I've written in lots of
different settings and formats
um lots of charitable leaders lots of
corporate leaders and private sector and
some public sector figures including
some recent politicians some current
politicians in fact including the
current lead of the labor party so I've
read I've written speeches across lots
of different sectors and subjects and
what I'm going to talk about now in the
next half an hour or so is the distilled
wisdom such as it is of the of the
things which apply to all of those
settings and I'll I'll as I go along
I'll talk about some of the differences
and some of the
peculiarities of them but I want to
leave you both with it with a template
of what a good compositional process
might look like which might be
practically useful but also to make some
remarks along the way about what makes
for a good speech and what are the
components of something which might
endure because speeches which last are
rarer than we think there are thousands
are done every day and very few of them
will ever be committed to memory most of
them disappear
um but let's start at the beginning I
want to walk you through the whole
process of it and of course like any act
when you become accustomed to doing
something when you become proficient in
an act you do it more quickly than this
but I'm going to take us through it
quite slowly so as to labor each point
so as to emphasize the moments where the
process can go badly wrong and it often
does go badly wrong
everything I say is going to be obvious
I hope
um it's because good writing is not a
series of complicated Maneuvers it's
actually the endless reproduction of the
basics at a higher level each time it's
a bit like sport in that sense that the
people who are brilliant at football are
not doing something fundamentally
different from the people who are less
good at it they're just doing it better
and writing is like that so it's a
series of basic elements which I'm going
to give you put them in a certain order
and I'm going to lay the emphasis in
certain places which may not be so
obvious but the components of this
tutorial will be very familiar to you
the first familiar point is obviously we
have to begin by contemplating our
audience
it's so obvious in fact that we're
liable to forget this we're liable to
skimp on it because it's boring why do I
have to think about them but it's an act
of selection the first moment of writing
takes place when you contemplate who is
in the audience who do you regard as
your audience which may be a different
question from who's actually sitting
there before you
your audience may be extensive they may
be not in the room they may these days
be online or they may consume a
cut up and fragmented version of your
speech at a later date you've got to
think about all of those possible
audiences the only way that you can
cover an audience which is multiple and
very and with different characteristics
is to speak and write in plain English
and this is something which will recur
as I as I speak that the the um the
language the sectional language the
idiom of the particular private
vocabulary is the enemy of good
communication particularly when we have
a multi-disciplined multifarious
audience we need to acquire a language
which which we've all got in fact which
is the language of educated plain
English because that language will
always satisfy the expert who will never
say I wish you'd say that again only in
more technical language but at the same
time it's also possible to make somebody
who's not part of the initiated
understand what you're saying so the
meeting point between the experts and
the non-expert is that the level of
playing educated English and that
audience map that we're drawing is a
crucial component of making selections
about what we're going to include
because I need to have a sense of the
degree of expertise my audience has are
they do they know a lot or do they know
very little I need to know where they
are I need to know broadly speaking what
do they think because what's going to
follow in this piece of writing is an
attempt to persuade them of something or
at least persuade some of them of
something that may be those in the
audience will already agree with what
I've got to say in which case The
Exchange is going to be much less
interesting there's always a part of a
political speech which is an attempt to
Rally the faithful to to flatter you
with things that you already think and
to to enlist myself in the things that
you are already thinking and that
there's another nice feeling there but
nothing really serious is taking place
because there's no conflict and serious
speech writing is about conflict so I
need to locate where the conflict is in
this exchange and I need to find the
people in this audience who don't quite
think what I think and on whom I'm going
to perform some kind of act where I'm
going to try and shift them I'm going to
try and move them and the use of the
emotional term is quite telling because
that's what I'm going to try and do I'm
going to try and move them
I can't be too ambitious here I can't
realistically hope in the course of a
30-minute
monologue move somebody's world view
fundamentally that's not going to happen
but I need to have a limited ambition I
need to have a range within which I
might persuade you to move your position
somewhat or at least question the
validity of the position that you begin
with so I need to have a sense of what
is the exchange I'm about to take this
it's about to take place in the piece of
writing I'm going to do and you can see
when you think of it like that you're
already making a whole series of
selections about what you will and what
you won't talk about and then what you
will and you won't include so I'm
writing already writing in this process
I'm describing is going to come very
late and this is the key to the
prevention of the Apparently glamorous
condition known as writer's block it's
always intrigued me that only writers
are allowed to say they have a sort of
disease that prevents them from doing
any work I mean if if anybody else turn
up at your house like the the plumber
turned up and said I'm so sorry I just I
just can't get started I've got sort of
plumber's block
you'd say please stop being so lazy get
on with it and the same is true of
writers I mean you really just have to
get on with it and and this this as I
say apparently glamorous condition of
writer's block is in fact usually a sort
of thinking block is that it's not that
we can't write it's that we don't know
what to say we don't know what we're
about to do
if you think clearly through the process
of writing and you're very clear what
you want to say it is then almost
impossible not to write because it's
easy to do so and this is the second
component of the the process that every
piece of good writing stands or falls on
the clarity of its Central proposition
and if you can't tell me in a single
sentence what you're trying to say then
you don't know and if you don't know
then you're not ready to start
and although a finished text is going to
have many subordinate
arguments and secondary thoughts and
digressions and illustrations and
anecdotes it's also going to have
something which is a driving force it's
going to have a governing idea it's
going to have a proposition and that
proposition must be something which is
not banal the bane of most speech
writing is not that it's bad or that
it's
poorly written is that it's boring it's
banal it begins with a platitude and
therefore it never ascends to anything
other than banality and most corporate
writing is of that kind and the private
sector is absolutely full of terribly
banal writing and the reason for this is
that the writer has not had the courage
to isolate a genuine proposition at the
beginning now that genuine proposition
must be something with which a
reasonable person might disagree
it doesn't have to therefore be
controversial because we're not
necessarily writing a polemic but it
does have to be something where on upon
which you can imagine another side so if
I were to say something like I'm going
to write a speech about brexit that is
not a good proposition because it
doesn't say anything there's no
disagreement there or if I were to say
I'm going to write a speech for a
corporate leader on
um the fact that our people are our
greatest asset that's not a good
proposition either because it's so banal
because nobody would in their right mind
would argue the opposite no one would
say we're going to stand up and speak
for 20 minutes about how our people are
all totally useless
now that might be true but it's not
something you'd ever say so and
therefore that there's no conflict in
this proposition there's nobody then on
the other side in the audience thinking
I don't agree nothing is happening so we
have to have a proposition with with
which at least it's possible to disagree
it has to be something that has a
another side so if I were writing a
piece on brexit it would have to be
something along the lines of brexit is a
was and is a magnificent idea which has
been going swimmingly all along
because it is possible to disagree with
that proposition
likewise I could say the opposite and I
it would then have the virtue of truth
if I said the opposite but I could also
find that people I can imagine people
who disagree with me and that's a
crucial thing when we get that when we
get a statement which is both pertinent
to the that section of the audience
you've decided you want to move and with
and you've isolated something that they
don't think then you've got the basis of
a speech at this point we've done an
awful lot of editorial selection and
we've absolutely ensured that it's not
going to be difficult to start writing
because we know what we're doing and I'd
really implore you if you're if you are
writing something to spend perhaps the
bulk of your time up to this point that
getting that core proposition might come
quickly if you know your field well and
you know exactly what you're doing but
it might not it might take quite a long
time it might take two or three goes you
might go down a blind alley you might
you might find that the the original all
thought you had doesn't quite work you
might need to research it you might need
to read you might need to discuss it I'm
very experienced in doing this I do all
of those things all the time and I'm
always searching for it and Margaret
drabble put this beautifully once when
she was asked about her latest novel she
said it's I mean said it's going really
well instead of uh you know I've
basically finished all I've got to do
now is write it
and she works like this she has it
someone Rush she works like this a lot
of the time she has it so intricately
planned and all the conflicts plotted in
her mind sometimes on a sort of
elaborate map on paper that the actual
composition of it then becomes
pleasurable uh and and not that's not to
say you don't find new things in the
composition of course you do
particularly in the writing of fiction
but also in the writing of a speech of
course you surprised yourself of course
you do it's not it's not absolutely a
map as such it's a guide and it's a it's
a form of discipline it was what you
then do in the in the writing is you're
always looking back at that Central
proposition I sometimes in fact write it
in a on a Post-It note and stick it in
front of me so as to keep myself
disciplined and ordered and the the if
you can't get it on the Post-it note in
the first place it's too long and it
acts as a kind of discipline I'm always
thinking that when I'm going into the
next section of the of the writing am I
still answering that question is this in
some way a deepening or an elaboration
of that Central proposition and if it
isn't I've got to ask myself well why
not because as Arthur Miller said all
good writing is like an organism there's
nothing wasted everything refers back
everything is used and so the real
discipline comes when you have got the
skill to take a wonderful story or a
great joke but expel it from the text
because it's not relevant it's really
difficult to do sometimes because you
think well it's going to be a great
moment if I tell that joke the audience
will love it they'll think I'm a very
funny character and they'll feel
sympathy for me but it's not actually
pertinent to this particular speech all
I've got these facts and they're really
telling and important but they don't
actually tell this particular story
having the skill and the discipline to
take them out is is the actual that's
when you know you're doing well
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas